these voters in gabon's capital liberal
are choosing a president members of
parliament and the municipal Council the
country is Rich with oil minerals and
other natural resources but many people
say the wealth hasn't Rich them 30% of
companes leave on less than $2 a day
have no jobs and struggle to meet their
basic needs corruption is Rife and the
gap between the rich and poor keeps
widening
we're in a moment where gabanes know
what they want we're in a country
governed by the rule of law we're
waiting for the votes to be counted
transparently we want the best person to
win president Ali Bongo onba is Seeking
a third time in office his family has
dominated gabon's politics for nearly
six decades his late father Omar Bongo
was President for 42 years he died in
2009 and his son took over Bongo
suffered a stroke in 2018 while he was
recovering a group of soldiers attempted
to overthrow the government some of his
critics argue that he's not fit enough
to rule
effectively his main rival Albert Ono
Oso was endorsed by an opposition
Coalition called alteron 2023 the
grouping of six presidential candidates
recently United
what is going on is not really uh the
expression of a free and fair election
when the polling stations are not open
in time where there this absence of
poing stations in several localities in
Gabon and outside of
Gabon in 2016 the presidential poll was
disputed violence broke out several
people were killed and many injured the
then opposition leader Jean ping who
came second claimed the results were
rigged some gabes are also concerned
about last minute changes to electoral
laws and a decision to lock out
International observers and foreign
journalists they say they're not
confident that the election will be free
or Fair Katherine soy
aler make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from
aler